donner une seconde vie aux appareils
électroménagers se le credo du magasin
envie de trappes chaque année 1100
tonnes de déchets sont collectés dans
cet atelier on démonte on répare et on
remet à neuf
ensuite direction la boutique où les
appareils sont mises en vente à petits
prix et avec une garantie d'un an et ça
permet à toute une partie de la
population et à des consommateurs de
plus en plus soucieux d' démarche
environnementale de s'équiper à moindre
coût bien évidemment puisque nous
revendons ensuite ces matériels à avec
un coût bien inférieur au prix neuf ce
mardi matin
la déléguée interministérielle à
l'économie sociale et solidaire a été
invité à visiter l'entreprise car en vie
c'est aussi la volonté d'agir pour
l'emploi l'entreprise lutte contre la
précarité et l'exclusion
objectif offrir un travail une formation
et un revenu aux trappistes les plus
éloignés de l'emploi
83% des personnes qui sont accueillis
ici ensuite débouche sur un cdd un cdi
ou une formation qualifiante
donc c'est une très belle réussite sur
cette capacité à réinsérer des personnes
dans l'emploi à ses débuts en 2012
envie embauché sept salariés en contrat
d'insertion aujourd'hui ils sont vingt à
pouvoir profiter d'un cdi
un contrat à durée déterminée
d'insertion les contrats d'insertion
sont des contrats à durées courtes que
l'on peut renouveler pour une période de
deux ans maximum
donc si c'est une rotation en fait de
deux personnels dès lors qu'elles sont
qu'ils sont formés ils retrouvent un
emploi dans les entreprises de la région
le groupe en vie existe depuis 30 ans
aujourd'hui 45 magasins sont implantés
en france
parmi les 2500 salariés deux mines sont
en contrat d'insertion